with Tekken 7 right around the corner we
invited fighting game legend mr. naps to
our studio to play some friendly games
and he proceeded to beat the crap out of
us all with one hand watch him dominate
on our live stream while hardly lifting
a finger and don't forget to subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more Tekken
and fighting game coverage who is
playing next Ben get back in there
Benjamin Janka get back in there alright
mr. Nath's is going to continue to play
one-handed and let's see if Ben can
defend himself
we believe in you down back to get some
distance in there
does anyone know how to make Jack
seven-plus goal right now so sorry the
cosa honey close-up we believe you can
fly we believe you can touch the sky
yeah just too much on post get some
distance don't know I'm too close
he can't move efficiently right now
there you go well painful here we go
ah that's actually good pretty good okay
[Laughter]
well you figure out how to fly so
there's that try some some grabs since
he is the one hand right now okay my
left hand the breaker grab really far as
he is moving forward try grabs I'll have
to jump back to the button needs to do
something there you go do it again do it
again
you got this blue let's see if we can do
a rage art right now try good try good
try
all right hi chasity well male I'd like
to get beat by this one-handed told you
in the club wait what character you
gonna use for you to vote for I'm
sticking either a mirror Metro Canada
for fun cuz and uh let's see replicate
or showed you a mere match mere match
you're a mere match wish me luck
mr. Nath's is at a handicap right now so
his movement is gonna be a little
delayed less efficient so let's try to
use that 3d space no no I pick my left
movement is important any more tips any
more hot tips anyone gonna sing Britney
Spears distract him um gotta help me
you got a singer dad oh yes sometimes
you now got soothing voice yeah that can
you sing Oh better so for the people
famous tree with your least favorite
music least favorite music yeah I'm
pretty open mind I like all kinds of
music what is the most annoying song to
you in the whole world about that yeah
what is it
I can't think of it right now
I'm the most annoying sound yeah ah okay
how about cotton eye Joe cuz that song
annoys the hell out of you
yes yes I broke yeah let's go for some
grabs as soon as he starts to move in go
for some grabs and brick throws as
efficiently tooth there you go okay yeah
that's gonna fit again on his heels
ooh nice of the version I know chasity
here we go who's who well confused I'm
in blue okay
I take it as a compliment that you
didn't know
oh nice slow oops
ooh there we go now we're talking nice
power crush oh you go that's okay
okay still in this counter so tense in
here it is too tense please someone talk
I'm sweating right now I'm sweating
that's actually one thing it's very hard
about Tekken is playing and speaking at
the same time like it's two different
disciplines it is oh my god playing and
singing I've been tab is doable it is I
do it all the time actually
awesome button
Oh God I think missing mountains he is a
part of Cobra Kai no mercy
it doesn't matter he's going you guys
sweep the leg wait to the wall
alright nice throw whooping oh whoa whoa
rays are coming out he's in the air good
block oh boy yeah Oh
textbook throw break oh all right I got
around hi alright uh who's gonna offend
me she believed me Mike G be back in my
GP you back